CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
WELL. GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY DODD THE.
RHIZOME GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG HELLO
HUESO TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING MORE
OCK AROUND NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO INNER
TURN. NUMBER WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT BUT ALL THE SENATORS
IN OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RIGHTS WILL BE LEADING PRAYER
THIS MORNING BUYER CHAPLAIN.
SHOULD A HAPPY NEW YEAR TO
SYSTEM CHAU GORMAN. AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING. WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ. SO WE BRING OURSELVES
INTO GOD'S PRESENCE. AND WE
BEGIN WITH MENDING BLESSING BUT
RICH BY JAN RICHARDSON. ALL MY
FRIENDS TAKE CARDS. THE WORK OF
REPAIR IS ACHING AND ITS
SLOWNESS AND BEAUTIFUL IN THE
INCHES BY WHICH IT WILL ARRIVE.
DO NOT PRAY TO BE PATIENT BUT
TO PERSIST. ASK FOR THE
INSURANCE THAT HELPS US LEARN
TO BREATHE IN THE MIDST OF FEAR.
TO LOVE IN THE PRESENCE OF
SORROW. AND TO DREAM WITHIN THE
RENDERING OF THE WORLD'S THAT
MIGHT BE MADE. LOVING GOD OF
MERCY AND COMPASSION HELP US TO
BE PATIENTS WITH THE SLOWNESS
OF OUR PROCESS THESE. MAY WE
ENTERED THE JUDGMENTS AND LACK
OF SPPORT THAT'S WE SOMETIMES
ENCOUNTER. AS WE SEEK TO BRING
WHOLENESS AND HARMONY TO OUR
WORLD A MAN. FIVE OF IT STATES
OF AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY TO THE WRONG. THANK YOU
SISTER THANK YOU CENTER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A. VERY SPECIAL
RECOGNITION HERE TODAY WE WANT
TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
LEADER GROVE. YOU BETTER BRING
FORWARD SOME SPECIAL FOLKS
CEDAR GROVE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT IT'S
MY PREVENT A PRIVILEGE THIS
MORNING TO INTRODUCE THE
DAUGHTER IN SAN OF GREG MA HE
SERVES AS THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
POLICY DIRECTOR. SO KYLE Mà IS
GRADUATING FROM BAYLOR
UNIVERSITY IN WACO TEXAS
INFORMANTS WITH A DEGREE IN
MECHANICAL ENGINEERING NOW THIS
IS CHRISTMAS BREAK IN OVER THIS
CHRISTMAS BREAK HE'S BEEN HOW
MANY'S FLYING BACK TO TEXAS
LATER TODAY. AND WE WISH HIM A
SAFE JOURNEY IS IN IT FOR THE
GREAT FINAL SEMESTER THE LAST
FINAL SEMESTER THAT HE HAS
ALLEGE HIS SISTER CASSIDY IS
MAJORING IN MATHEMATICS AT
WILLIAM JESUP UNIVERSITY WHICH
IS LOCATED A FEW MILES FROM THE
CAPITAL IN ROCKLAND WHERE SHE
ALSO PLAYED FOR THE WOMEN'S
INTERCOLLEGIATE FOOTBALL TEAM
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT WHEN TALKING WITH
GREG HE'S EXTREMELY HAPPY THAT
IS CHILDREN DID NOT ENTER INTO
THE WORLD OF POLITICS BUT THAT
HE IS THERE FOCUSING ON IAN I
AM AND I'M SO PLEASE JOIN ME
IN. GIVING KILEY CASTING MOM TO
THE- MAYBE. I ALWAYS. WELCOME
TO YOU YOUR DAD IS ONE OF THE
WORK WITH SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU. MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON. WITH OUR AGENDA
TODAY MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. ARTS A
COMMITTEE THEY'RE GONNA BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE WITH MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN SEE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WILL BE REFERRED TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. ITEM FIFTY
THREE SB. ONE SEVEN FIVE I
DIDN'T FIFTY FOUR SB THREE
EIGHT. MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE SENATE JOURNALS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JANUARY SIX
THROUGH JANUARY NINTH TWENTY
TWENTY WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
SENATORS UNDER INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING OF BILLS. THOSE
BILLS YOU GUESSED IT ARE GONNA
BE DEEMED READ. WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON FILE.
MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY ONE AND
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE A ONE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY. MEMBERS IT'S NOW
TIME TO BE A RETURN TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS THIS WILL BE A
TIME FOR MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE SENATE WITH THEIR
JOURNEY MEMORIES WE LIKE TO BE
A TO START WITH. PRESIDENT PRO
TEM MACHEN'S. BETTER APPROACH
HIM ARE YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT.
THANK AND COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
A JUROR IN MEMORY OF FORMER SAN
DIEGO CITY COUNCIL MEMBER FLOYD
MORROW WHO PASSED AWAY IN
OCTOBER AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
SIX. MR MORROW WAS A DEDICATED
CIVIC LEADER WHO'S GOOD DEEDS
EARNED HIM THE RESPECT AND THE
ADMIRATION OF HIS COLLEAGUES
AND THE COUNTLESS INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING MYSELF WHO'S Là HE
TOUCHED. HE WAS BORN IN WICHITA
FALLS TEXAS AND GREW UP IN A
LECTURE UPON GRADUATING FROM
HIGH SCHOOL HE JOINED THE
UNITED STATES MARINES WHICH
BROUGHT HIM TO SAN DIEGO. AFTER
RECEIVING HIS BACHELOR'S AND
LAW DEGREE HE WORKED AT RYAN
AERONAUTICAL IN SAN DIEGO
BEFORE BECOMING DEPUTY CITY
ATTORNEY IN NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE. TWO YEARS LATER HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE SENATE CITY
COUNCIL TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
DISTRICT FIVE. HE WAS AN
ADVOCATE OF OPEN SPACES FOR
PUBLIC USE AND A HUGE CHAMPION
FOR THE PRESERVATION OF- TO THE
INTEL CODY CANYON  GORGEOUS
JIM IN SAN DIEGO. HE SUPPORTED
SOCIAL PROGRAMS SUCH AS MEALS
ON WHEELS WHICH HE SAW AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO FIGHT
POVERTY. COUNCILMAN FLOYD
MORROW IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
OF SIXTY FIVE YEARS MARLENE HIS
THREE CHILDREN DARLENE SHAUN
AND LANCE. AND HIS FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN. FIVE I MIGHT ADD
THAT HIS DAUGHTER IN LAW WAS.
MY FABULOUS CANINE PETS HAYLEY
AND JOEY JOEY THE CHALLENGING
ONE. HI THE GROOMER AND- I'D
YOU KNOW SO HIS LIFE TOUCHED MY
WAY SPECIFICALLY BUT ALSO
DIRECTLY PERSONALLY- AND SO
MANY WERE SAD TO HEAR WE
COULDN'T BELIEVE HE WAS EIGHTY
SIX YEARS OLD HE DIDN'T LOOK
IT. HE DIDN'T ACTED. I AND HE
CONTINUED UNTIL THE VERY END TO
CONTRIBUTE- TO SO MANY OF US IN
SO MANY WAYS SO PLEASE JOIN ME
IN HONORING THE MEMORY OF
COUNCIL MEMBER FLOYD MORROW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
PRESENT PROTECTING PLEASE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST SYMPATHIES
WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
BRING UP CENTER DRAWS A- AND
RESERVOIR COMPARED TO PERCENT.
YES THE FLOOR IS YOURS CAM.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING UP
MEMBERS TODAY ASK WILL JOIN IN
THE MEMORY OF ROSE A PORTAL.
THAT'S THE WAY ON DECEMBER
THIRTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. SHE WAS BORN IN
MONTHS AND NEIL COOL ONE. IN
NINETEEN THIRTY WHERE SHE
GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE AND
WORKED AS AN OFFICE MANAGER AS
AT A CIGAR COMPANY. BUT SHE
SOON LOST HER JOB AT A CIGAR
DISTRIBUTOR AND A HUSBAND OLD
WAS SENT TO A LABOR CAMP WHEN
THEY MADE THE REQUEST TO LEAVE
CUBA. IN ORDER SUPPORTER FAMILY
SHE SECRETLY AN ILLEGAL
ILLEGALLY STARTED TO SELL CAKES.
AFTER YEARS ON A WAIT LIST ROSA
AND HER FAMILY WERE ALLOWED TO
LEAVE CUBA IN THE SEVENTIES.
AND THEY ARRIVED IN LOS ANGELES.
UP WITH NO MONEY SURPRISE. WORD
I WOULD GOT A JOB AS A JANITOR
AND SHE BAKED AND SOLD CAKES
HER HOME FOR NEIGHBORS AND
FELLOW CUBAN IMMIGRANTS WITH A
SMALLLOAN THE FAMILY OPEN
PORTALS BAKERY AND CAFE. ON
SUNSET BOULEVARD IN ECHO PARK
WHICH IS MY DISTRICT. THE
BAKERY SOON BECAME FAMOUS NOT
ONLY FOR CUBAN CAKES BUT POTATO
BALLS AND BY NOW THAT AS WELL
AND SHE'S A STRUDEL STRAWBERRY
CAKES MANGLE MOST BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO APPEAL TO THE CHINESE
AND FILIPINO COMMUNITIES AND
EXPAND THEIR MENU. ALTHOUGH THE
BAKERY HAS EXPANDED TO OTHER
LOCATIONS IN BURBANK DOWNEY
WHEN THE PARK WAS COULD BE AND
THEN GLENDALE EACH STORE ALWAYS
HAS LONG LINES APPEARING TO BE
VERY CHAOTIC. BUT THERE IS A
SYSTEM THAT EVERYONE SOON
LEARNS IT ALSO ALSO BECOME MUCH
TOUCHSTONE FOR GENERATIONS OF
CUBAN IMMIGRANTS IN LOS
ANGELES. SHE MAY BE GONE BUT
HER LEGACY WILL SURELY AND
YOU'RE NOT MERELY FOR THE GOOD
FOOD BUT FOR THE OPEN EMBRACE
OF THE CITY AND COUNTRY THAT
WELCOMED HER IN RETURN. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN HONORING DRAW SAYS
LEGACY AS A STRONG WOMAN
DETERMINED TO RAISE HER FAMILY
WITH FULL ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
AND AS AN IMMIGRANT SEEKING
FREE. OF THE GENERATIONS BEFORE
HER HE WENT FROM ILLEGAL KID TO
CUBA. OUR THE FOURTEEN THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS A DAY AND THE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES HE LEAVES
BEHIND HER HUSBAND I WILL OF
SIXTY FOUR YEARS OUR CHILDREN
GET THREES AND A LITTLE AND MY
DADDY THAT AND- SEVEN GRAND
CHILDREN TODAY I ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN EXTENDING OUR HEART
FELT CONDOLENCES TO HER FAMILY
AND COMMUNITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO. AN INSPIRING
STORY WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU. WE
NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO A-
FINAL JOURNEY MEMORY WAS
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MEMBERS I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY. FOR RICHARD MORE IN
MISSOURI. RICHARD WAS A DYNAMIC
FORCE IN CALIFORNIA'S FOOD AND
RESTAURANT RENAISSANCE STARTING
IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES AT LECOCQ
RESTAURANT IN LOS ANGELES THEN
THE ORIGINAL VICTORIA STATION A
RESTAURANT THAT WAS IN BOX CARS
IN SAN FRANCISCO BUT THEN WENT
ON TO BECOME A CHAIN. AS THE
FIRST GENERAL MANAGER OF
SHAPING EASE. THEN ON TO
OPENING HIS OWN RESTAURANTS
BELT BAR CESAR'S IN BERKELEY
CESAR'S IN OAKLAND AND MANY
OTHERS HE LEFT US ON DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH AFTER A YEAR LONG
BATTLE WITH CANCER. BORN IN
STOCKTON RICHARD HAD A DRY WIT
AND INFECTIOUS SENSE OF HUMOR
AND A TALENT FOR MAKING PEOPLE
FEEL. AND EVERYONE WHO I'VE
EVER SPOKEN TO WHO MADAM AND
DEALT WITH HIM HAD ONLY GOOD
THINGS TO SAY ABOUT HIM HOW
MANY OF US WILL HAVE THAT WHEN
WE PASS- HE STUDIED RESTAURANT
MANAGEMENT A CALL CAL OLY
POMONA. NNE WORKED BRIEFLY FOR
JACKSON BROWNE FOR THE MUSICIAN
JACKSON BROWNE WHO THEN WAS HIS
LIFELONG FRIEND. AFTER
GRADUATING RICHARD WENT TO WORK
AS MAITRE DE FOR CHEF CAN
FRANK'S LE COKE IN LA IN THE
EARLY EIGHTIES. ENSURE FRANK
ALSO COUNTED RICHARD AS A
LIFELONG FRIEND AND HE SAID
THAT RICHARDS RELENTLESS
POSITIVE ATTITUDE TOWARDS LIFE
WAS INFECTIOUS. AND DEFINE TO
WE WAS. SO THEN SHORTLY AFTER
LECOCQ RICHARD MOVE BACK TO THE
BAY AREA IN ALICE WATERS HIRED
HIM AS THE VERY FIRST GENERAL
MANAGER AT CHEZ PANISSE NOW FOR
ANY OF YOU WHO FOLLOWED SHAPING
USES HISTORY. FUNCTIONING AS A
BUSINESS WAS NOT IN THE
RESTAURANTS WORLD VIEW IN ITS
FIRST DECADE OF EXISTENCE
RICHARD PATIENTLY BROUGHT
SHAPING EASE INTO THE BUSINESS
WORLD. A COMPUTER RISING THEIR
PAY ROLL THEIR- THEY'RE ALL OF
THEIR SYSTEMS AND OF COURSE HE
HAD TO DO THAT VERY PATIENTLY.
AFTER TWELVE YEARS AT CHEZ
PANISSE RICHARD OPENED HIS OWN
TOPLESS BAR BAR CESAR WHICH IS
STILL RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO
SHAPING THE CIVIC VISIT
BERKELEY. THEN HE WENT ON TO
OPEN THE SECOND PARSEES ARE A
RESTAURANT NAMED ASSEMBLE IN
RICHMOND NEXT TO THE ROSIE THE
RIVETER MEMORIAL AND MORE
RECENTLY TABLE FOOD AND DRINK
IN RANCHO SANTA FE. AT RICHARD
CELEBRATE LIFE WHICH WAS JUST
LAST WEEK. JACKSON BROWNE
FONDLY REMEMBERED RICHARD AS A
CONSISTENT SUPPORTER OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE MOVEMENTS IN THE
SEVENTIES AND UNTIL TODAY. AND
REMEMBER HIM OPENING UP SHAPING
NIECE WHEN EVER JACKSON
BROWNE'S BEYOND OR OTHER BANDS
WERE IN THE AREA. TO HOLD
BENEFIT CONCERTS FOR THE
VARIOUS SOCIAL MOVEMENTS
WHETHER IT WAS ANTI NUCLEAR
ANTI ON WAR VERY SUTHERS. AND
THEN AFTER HIS STINT AT CHEZ
PANISSE WHEN HE OWNED HIS OWN
RESTAURANTS HE AND HIS WIFE
THROUGH ME WELCOME TO BàN
STAFF AND VOLUNTEERS AND THEY
WERE ALWAYS INSISTED. THEY WERE
PREPARING THE FOOD AND MAKING
IT AVAILABLE NOT SO MUCH FOR
THE- THE JACKSON BROWNE'S BUT
RATHER FOR THE ROADIES THE
STAFF AND THEVOLUNTEERS. WHO
ALL ACCOMPANIED THOSE FIVE WHEN
THEY WERE DOING THOSE CONCERTS.
HUMBLE FUNNY INSURANCE RICHARD
WILL TRULY BE MISSED BY HIS
WIFE ROOMY SHIBATA MISSOURI HIS
CHILDREN JACK MISS HEARING KATE
MADERA CUMAE DODI SERENITY DODA
DODI HIS SISTER NANCY HIS
NINETY ONE YEAR OLD MOTHER
VIRGINIA AND ALL OF US WHO
LOVED HIM. THERE'S GONNA THANK
YOU SO MUCH IN OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES MISSOURI FAMILY.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS THIS MORNING. MADAM
PRESIDENT THE DESK IS CLEAR IN
RECORD TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT. WHAT A WEEK-
IT'S BEEN BUSY IT IT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE IT'S ONLY BEEN SEVERAL
DAYS BUT- I HOPE YOU ENJOY YOUR
TRIP HOME ENJOY THE WEEKEND
BACK IN YOUR DISTRICTS AND WE
WILL SEE YOU ON MONDAY JANUARY
THIRTEENTH AT TWO PM THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER ATKINS LAYS
INJURED ON THE SENATE THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
JOURNEY OF MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE'LL RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO
PM IN A REMINDER THAT WE HAVE A
LONGER WEEK WILL BE GOING
THROUGH FRIDAY NEXT WEEK. HAVE
A WONDERFUL WEEKEND